okay so today for the last topic in this
series on the local and regional level
the urban and spatial planning we have
repeated here the three basic parts
where you find this in the t books yeah
so sorry should be used to this by now
but there we go after this lecture I
hope you will have understood how urban
and spatial planning can integrate
ecosystem service is an idea on how
policy design can make use of ecosystem
service concept and incorporate values
and an overview of useful approaches and
tools and a point that's yeah I've been
trying to make over the whole series but
would like to again reinforce that
monetary values are but an input in a
wider decision-making process so very
briefly objectives of urban planning
well obviously to provide public
services and infrastructure to enhance
citizens quality of life and to foster
economic growth
what do ecosystem services have to do
with this well if you look at these
different topic areas its from most of
them it's pretty evident regarding
ecosystem services and environmental
issues
what can local administrations what can
open manager actually do well they can
act as a role model in the sense of
managing municipal resources in an
ecosystem service conscious way they can
promote and set incentives for others to
act in such a way and they can regulate
thus obligating others to take certain
aspects into account you find in Chapter
four table 4.1 a whole set of different
options ideas that are pertinent to the
to the urban context how this can be
approached from from different angles
and concerning different services now
the relationship is most obvious if we
look at water
fresh water provisioning we saw on that
one third of the world cities depend at
least for part of the drink drinking
water on protected areas wastewater
treatment another obvious example so
this is the Uganda but example that
you've gone in just one third of the
world's biggest cities so we're not
talking all cities coastal protection
and flood protection so these these are
the areas where it's most obvious you
see a strong consciousness on these
issues you have the whole debate on
green infrastructure here in the States
we have a which is basically about water
management as I understood we have a
similar debate on green infrastructure
in Europe which is slightly more towards
connectivity and habitats and replacing
very infrastructure but these are the
entry points where this is obviously
entering now what I want to focus on is
a little bit more the process and I want
to use two examples one is here from the
United States from Napa Valley where
they've had an incredible amount of
floods and the city of 70,000 over the
last hundred fifty years they've they've
had something like 50 to 70 flood events
so every two to three years something
happens there and after another big
flooding event in 1986 finally there it
was a whole movement that emerged
opposing the the plan of the American
courts of engineers to build even more
colored sand and dredged the the the
river more but rather to approach this
in a more comprehensive way and they
founded the so-called Living River
initiative this is a very very broad
movement involving 25 agencies and
plenty of individuals from all kinds of
different directions and expertise and
jointly they've come up with a plan for
integrated River management to prevent
damage by flooding and the 400 million
dollars that this costs divided 50
percent
the local and other 50% comes from the
national level through the course of
corporal engineers and the 50% that
needed to be raised locally there was a
decision to increase the local sales tax
by one percent over the next 20 years in
order to cover this cost so if in this
country someone agrees to raise taxes
they must really care about the issue
now the plan envisaged to enhance
several ecosystem services so not only
address the flooding issue but also
recreation tourism it actually involved
as you might be able to kind of see from
the from the picture opening up the
flatbed and allowing marshes and
wetlands on either side of the river
which imply taking down some properties
and buying out some of the people but it
has led to two big reconstruction in the
areas that were formerly in risk of
flooding it has led to approximately 400
million dollars private investment of
rebuilding hotels and and and business
and residences and it has created
recreation areas in the center of the
city and made the whole center of the
city much more attractive so property
values increased substantially and
insurance rates were actually reduced
they there's an estimate that I think
3,000 properties will have lower or no
flood insurance as soon as the project
is finished so if you're in such a
quote-unquote lucky situation that the
pressure is high enough you can have a
broad coalition of different interests
actually getting together and and
implementing these things next I'd like
to talk about the a study in Cape Town
and now in Cape Town the mainstreaming
was much more of a challenge in the
sense that there was not a broad
understanding and
and and movement to actually foster and
take into account ecosystem services and
this story is the ISM and yeah this
story is about the environmental
administration commissioning a study and
we'll look through we'll look at it
through the lens of the Teebs six steps
that we've introduced in the first
lecture and have been applying to
several of the case studies so first
step is to specify the policy and
management issues and they actually did
they didn't follow this approach but
they actually did this step because the
approach wasn't there yet when they did
this whole thing and so as I said the
environmental management department
commissioned this study but before they
handed it over to the consultants and
and the the purpose the objective was to
make an economic case for increased
spendings city spending on natural asset
management so a clear objective for
which to produce the values now before
the study commenced before they
commissioned the consultant they engaged
with all other departments within the
city management that had some impact on
or some management of natural resources
and with the financial department
they've involved them throughout the
process and this has been crucial so
second step identify and prioritize
ecosystem services well they did that as
a participatory process with these
different line managers using one-to-one
interviews as well as facilitated
sessions they had five criteria for
selecting the relative importance of the
ecosystem services and it an impact
matrix basically addressing who benefits
from these services this partially
covers steep step six
the link to economic development the
possibility of the city to actually
influence these services and a system of
risk ranking so which of these service
design
and can be can be helped
step 3 defining information needs so
they decided to value priority list
services by a combination of primary
valuation techniques and some benefit
transfer estimates there were in the
lucky position to have data for the city
for four more years for some of the
areas and again involving the line
managers and especially the finance
department was key to focusing on actual
information needs so what was the
message what is the wording what are the
terms what are the assumptions that
these people have to take up this
information and make it useful step four
assessing the actual value so here we
have a couple of in this case values and
runt rather than in dollars and the
methods being used what what is not so
clear in the study Knight tried
understanding the the chapter last night
is on water purification wait waste
treatment the only estimates are there
that I found there were cleanup costs to
recover certain water purification
functions of some of their pond or lake
structures what I found interesting is
this sixth ecosystem services that was
prioritized the aesthetics and sense of
place related values and here they used
a whole combination of arguments and
you'll see the first two are entirely
qualitative combined then so evidence of
the importance of green spaces for
health as well as to attract skilled
entrepreneurs that of course important
for the economic development then Cape
Town has an important part of film and
advertising industry and there they did
a direct estimate of the natural asset
related components and values and
they had a couple of examples where they
could illustrate influence on property
values and and influence of
rehabilitation restoration projects for
example of some of the rivers in the in
the city that had influence property
values significantly now values as such
are not enough to make the business case
so what they agreed on calculating are
these two ratios one is basically a
benefit cost ratio between the
investments and the expected increase in
gross Geographic product so not looking
at national but rather regional product
which were 1.2 to 2 times higher than
for the overall investments by the city
and so called unit reference value where
they calculated what expenditure is
necessary the level of the city to
create a rands worth of benefits and
this was 16% as compared to for example
water infrastructure where it takes much
more investment now coming back to this
as a process what was what was important
important was there was a clear
objective in this case to make a
business case they consulted with the
relevant people outside the
environmental sector it was a
participatory process of prioritizing
the relevant ecosystem services
there was a strong focus in the whole
argumentation on human benefits not only
in the sense of yes we need clean water
but also the importance to attract
skilled labor for example which is
something that talked to people of the
economic development department however
in view of competing demands and this
came at a very bad moment because they
had just finished the stadium really
rehabilitating the stadium for the world
soccer championship and that was of
course was considerable overspending
there was not much flexibility in
moving budget to towards more investment
in in environmental field nonetheless
the the environmental Department
concluded that it was a fantastic
foundation for further development of
environmental fiscal reform strategies
they considered the process was as
important as the outcome in terms of
study and were quite aware that this
might not immediately lead to to to
change in budgeting but there was then a
plan by these different by these
different line managers and departments
to jointly search for new financing
sources for different initiatives and it
has created a lot of understanding and
and common ground it within the city
administration so any questions on this
pollen
well I think that part is quite
well-protected in in in this moment in
there is a certain level of awareness it
has the botanical garden one of the most
famous ones in the world etc but I think
it helped tremendously especially for
all these yeah water they had they had
very deteriorated rivers and lakes and
when I was there at the Eclair
conference in March we had an excursion
to one of these lakes that is referred
to as a problem in in the study and
definitely something has happened there
in the mean time so I think it was more
this awareness creation that rivers are
just waste dumps and that they actually
prover present services and they have
South Africa has it's working for water
program where they've had a tremendous
amount of public investment into
recovering water bodies which has also
helped but that has come in from the
national level
and not a way of any study looking into
what has actually happened in the
meantime I think this is a two thousand
seven or eight study and I know that the
the city has invested in some parts I
don't know how much of the city budget
went in there or if they were available
to attract outside funding which might
well be the car the case for this
ecologic
park I was referring to just now if
you're interested in the details they
are - the reports are just as long as it
as these URLs make you think actually
the one on the methodology is quite
concise but the final report is very
very detailed okay from from there I'd
like to talk about an approach that's
called eco budget it's an accounting
system for municipal Environmental
Management it has been developed by a
Clay International Council of local
governments for more sustainable
management and has been applied by
several of them it allows to plan
control monitor report and on and
evaluate consumption of natural
resources as well as certain service
functions you see here some ecosystem
services noise it's probably not
directly an ecosystem services but a
related environmental issue the idea is
to keep spending of these resources
within a master budget so important part
of the process is to identify
environmental targets then it sets up
this accounting system and measures the
achievement against these targets to see
how successful it has been it
complements the traditional budgeting
accounting system so it's another
component that municipalities can add on
to their systems buy-in this is an
environmental component
usually have the of spending and human
resources and and finance etc but most
municipalities don't look into their
environmental budget and it uses
physical units which makes it easier in
most cases to set up the system it
allows for for participation and there
are several examples in in the in
Chapter four you'll find an example from
from the Philippines where they started
measuring okay how much mangroves how
much trees how much open spaces do we
have and realize the importance of these
for tourism for waste management for for
fisheries and an actual poverty le
reduction programs so they started with
a much more conscious management of
these and were able to achieve most of
their objectives over the last couple of
years it has another example from Sweden
where the target setting was mainly
towards energy independence becoming
independent of fossil fuel energy this
is a very forest dominated municipality
where again this kind of target setting
and accounting has helped to achieve
these goals over a couple of years so
next moving on to spatial planning and
just as an introduction spatial planning
what is the objective well an
orientation to where different land use
options should take place
it varies tremendously depending on
where you are here in the States it's
mainly at you municipal level but you'll
have totally different systems from one
state to the next probably also from one
municipality to the next there are
countries that have very hierarchical
nested planning like Germany for example
where you have you have certain
orientations from the national level and
you have a master plan that is already
binding towards certain users and then
municipalities can within this these
margins they can do their they are
planning what is
what is also interesting is that some
countries have it in the sense of
developing development policies so it's
the formulation of objectives and goals
towards which they want to move which is
more we are trying to appeal to people
that's move in this direction whereas in
many other countries it's actually
legally binding so in Germany if you
construct something outside a
construction area you have you have a
serious problem with whereas this is not
the case in in all countries yeah an
important instrument our master plans
that usually come up with some kind of
consecutive sequenced actions that might
be necessary to in the long term achieve
certain goals an important instrument
that is used almost worldwide is
environmental impact assessment and it
follows basically the same steps all
over so beginning with a screening to
determine which proposals are actually
subject to to impact assessment and
there are some very interesting cases of
for example the UK passed passed
legislation or not not even legislation
but required certain fishing operations
to do environmental impact assessment
which immediately led to a different way
of approaching this and looking at
certain ecosystem services affected
which they usually don't do in their in
their management so it varies
tremendously what is or not subject to
EIA scoping so the identification of
which impacts are we actually going to
be looking at that will then be be put
into the terms of reference and it's
these two steps we're including
ecosystem services is most important or
where it makes most sense some ecosystem
services will always be included in some
way but many in many places and in
situations it's not a comprehensive
inclusion so this is where there's
potential for
improvement and then it goes on with the
assessment study as such which comes up
with an environmental management plan a
review which is usually with some kind
of public involvement where obviously
there's another opportunity to to call
for accounting for for ecosystem
services the decision-making and then
the follow-up where again if ecosystem
services are included in the monitoring
we already a huge step ahead so this as
one powerful instrument where local
municipalities can by influencing the
terms of reference make sure that
certain services are included now this
is another example from South Africa to
illustrate a planning framework for four
different parts of of a municipality a
municipality characterized again by high
unemployment by large proportion of the
population depending directly on
ecosystem services to sustain
livelihoods especially water but also
also food and what they did was a
strategic catchment assessment so they
subdivided this into eight different
units and and came up with indicators on
the state or condition of certain
services in these units indicators on
the pressures that that affect these
these services and the responses that
are already in place for eleven
different they call it themes but
basically it's its ecosystem services
they also did a value estimate of over
all values of services but I think in
terms of planning in terms of planning
the indicators and the indications of
what could possibly be done have been
have been more decisive
so what did they do basically they
balance between supply and demand
assessed in each of the catchment units
and then color-coded according to the
balance of this which the these are the
ecosystem services taken into account
and then the different situations two of
the areas being in critical condition
one being in quite good condition and
the other somewhere in between you see
these little icons symbolizing the state
of the different of the different for
the different services each of this has
underlying some indicators Kavita has
put up the the entire document on the on
the classes system so you can have a
look at it's a very easily
understandable colorful graphical way of
conveying importance to people who
usually don't think in these terms well
I'm not this is a this is a study done
commissioned to a group of people who
have been trying to highlight here what
are the development potentials what are
the areas and what are the services in
the areas that might be crucial and they
they in fact I think that comes here
they establish different planning zones
so determining in these zones it would
be good to focus on conservation then
some open space or linkage zones and
some development zones in order to
orient where things would need to happen
but they don't and and they make some
proposals as to policy responses that
that could possibly be helpful taking
into account is that the municipalities
decision or do they need to link up with
the district or and things like that so
they give some indications on this
management but it's not an overall
development plan in the sense of okay
how can we attract investment from
somewhere else to really start moving
things quickly it's an area
characterized by a huge population
increase they have a population increase
of 8 percent per year so a lot of people
migrating into this area
and kind of trying to they have a harbor
to get employment opportunities there
and but kind of camping out in the open
spaces and and squatting etc because and
and employment opportunities are just
not nearly equivalent to what through
the inflow of people now South Africa in
general has very very high unemployment
rate so this is not a particular hot
spot but it's attractive enough to still
to still get a lot of people in there
and this is this is a way of trying to
at least conserve the the most crucial
bits of of ecological infrastructure if
you will to maintain the system
functioning and not to put another
burden onto the whole - the whole thing
in the sense of having then to struggle
for water and things like that as well
yeah so it's it's kind of background to
manage these but not a development plan
as such okay so this is a comparatively
you know it's quite broad in the sense
that they looked into into many
different indicators and services but
they try to communicate on a very basic
you know this color-coding idea and a
very basic level in order to get
attention and and outline possible
avenues okay so this is an example from
Indonesia where they had I mean this is
all so I'd say global trend when I first
started working in Latin America 20
years ago hardly any of the countries
had spatial planning established and
then there was a huge wave of organ
immune to territorial and practically
the entire continent and a lot of people
studying this and getting into this and
in Indonesia it's even more recent in
2007 that a new spatial planning law was
actually allowing or with actually open
a broom for policy to to influence there
and also taking it down to the district
levels so allowing for much more
location specific planning and so this
new law opened possibilities and in this
area and NGO forum okay
organized the visioning process so that
they came up with different options yeah
analyzing the the situation and this is
characterized by intense logging and
forest conversion to into plantations
which affect of course biodiversity but
also water regulation erosion similar to
the situations we we saw last time in
the looser National Park they got
support from from the natural capital
project which is a collaboration between
academic institutions here so mainly
Stanford and and different environmental
NGOs and they've put up this invest tool
which is a tool for mapping and
analyzing services and it's all
available on the web and you can enter
your own data there and according to the
level of detail of data that you have
the you can use different modules and it
goes all the way up to evaluation as
well if you have the necessary data to
to provide for this so what it basically
does is produce different maps here you
have one for water yield capacity of of
the area but they produce different maps
and over ladies and this then allows two
so what they did was compare this vision
that they developed with a
business-as-usual scenario and it allow
allows to make specific recommendations
again which areas should be prioritized
for forests for protection or for
restoration or where could you actually
allocate forest concessions with least
damage on overall
overall ecosystem services and with this
spatial distribution of course you can
also then highlight where are the
communities living where do you have
high incidence of poverty so which are
the areas you want to focus on with
regard to which types of services and
and instruments okay any questions
regarding this one yeah the yeah the
system is quite interesting because you
they I think they provide some ground
level of data from worldwide sources but
you can you can according to your data
will availability enter all kinds of
other data that you have available and
many countries do have remote sensing or
and that's also something that has
happened tremendously over the last
twenty years even in many developing
countries to compile it this type of
information to an extent that you have
quite a bit of it around but it's not
that easy to make it actually useful for
planning because it's hard to combine it
it implies a lot of management of the
data
yep you can access it on the internet
and download it and run it on your I
would say yes but I have to admit that I
don't really know the details I just
more or less believe what they told me
it can do but you should discuss this
with rosemary when she comes because
she's really an expert on these these
models and on other systems they are
developing because one of the big
drawbacks of this is that it's not a
dynamic model
yeah
yeah
in general I don't know how many of you
actually had a d2 report in their hands
or haven't looked through it at the end
of each chapter there's the section on
for further information which has what
we kind of could get our hands on with
regard to easily accessible manuals
tools databases software whatever and it
also has an annex where some of these
tools are and they all describe with one
or two sentences what what their basic
idea is and just go and check it out and
I know there's much more available we've
tried to update a little bit if you come
across something that's not in the
report yet please let me know as soon as
possible we're right in the middle of
copy editing so we can include that as
well okay
you don't know that we calculator you
can go to this way can I click on it
here can I go onto the Internet oops
see what happens so enter your zip code
where are we here 0 6 another one so
what kind of a tree would you like to
know about what I am it up tree okay I'm
going to put something okay well it
takes from zero to forty five but let's
put eighteen as something more realistic
and what kind of area are we looking at
single-family multifamily small
commercial business industrial or park
or other vacant land
so here you get your values
I'm sure it says somewhere we've
actually had a student doing a work on
the application of some of these tools
and he did a couple of interviews this
is where this works for the u.s. there
are some similar things in in other
countries but this is the most
comprehensive one definitely what is
nice is that it has these different
value categories and again we can then
see okay for whom is this important here
obviously an important part is property
value so a private benefit but we have
the stormwater which is interesting
beyond the private benefit and we also
have air quality co2 natural gas
whatever natural gas stands for okay how
do I get back to my presentation yeah
there we are so the city Green is
another interesting one quite similar a
little bit more integrated not not
entirely looking at a single tree but
more at different settings but so
there's there's plenty of software and
possibilities to get value estimates on
different functions okay now page
potentials and challenges of arguing
with ecosystem services in planning so
this is the point I made earlier in
response to Pablo it is an opportunity
to really look and do a forward-looking
planning and not only place restrictions
and that also means you can focus on
issue that people are much can relay to
much easier than for example
biodiversity conservation which for many
people in many places remains very
abstract but when you start
taking this down into some services that
might have biodiversity as a co benefit
then it's easier to communicate and and
operate with now accounting frameworks
need regular updates and that is of
course a challenge and quite an input
that you have to make into a process
it's it's therefore decisive that you
set easily understandable reliable
indicators but also easily accessible
indicators so it makes a lot of sense to
actually work with the people in the
municipality and look at what types of
indicators do they already have what are
they already reporting on will these
serve as proxies for for ecosystem
services or what will we needed to
complement this and I mean we we looked
at that with the with the Philippines
case the tuatara case if you a large
challenge is this invisibility of the
values of the things happening and if
you can find indicators that allow you
to communicate easily that you've
already won quite quite aways and one
interesting example was from a payment
for ecosystem service watershed example
in Peru where well Kohli bacteria where
one of the main water quality issues due
to livestock and maybe even also humans
being too close to the to the river so
it was something that was very easily
measurable they could very clearly and
quickly show this is improving and that
of course gets much more attention and
then people are much more willing to
actually enter into negotiations for a
payment scheme
that's something that you know this a
way to sort of
yeah well well there are plenty of
examples of cities trying to improve
their indicator systems especially also
for environmental issues if you look at
me into a lot of the local agenda21
processes they have some kind of
component of this sort where yeah you
have different agencies but also NGOs or
citizens getting together and especially
in biodiversity conservation it amateur
naturalist very important source of
information of data collecting and
upkeeping and within the Helmholtz
Association which is the Research
Association area we belong to they have
developed a sustainability approach that
is kind of where they formulate some
general rules and in areas and it's
designed to then with the community or
with the municipality select problem
areas in the municipality and then lead
them through a process of indicator
selection based on what they have and
what is readily available towards what
what might serve there so it's there's
plenty of experience of yeah trying to
translate this down into something that
is manageable and that can be kept up
over time and that that actually talks
to people in this regard now the same is
also valid with regard to two values
monetary values and valuation it's
pretty difficult to make the case more
than once using the same value and
therefore it's when you when you start
some kind of assessment it'll be
etcetera be at local whatever it's
important that you that you
conceptualize it in such a way that key
values can then
we be updated later on like the Caped
Sun study with regard to recreation was
able to recur to to earlier estimates
and then just adjust for a number of
people or adjust for certain changes so
that they could use this and as I've
tried to highlight the the important
point is we need political opportunities
and but whenever they arise we should be
able to readily provide the necessary
information and data and therefore
keeping this kind of a more pragmatic
approach in mind pays off in the in the
long term so then I'd like to finish up
with two slides of more or less
conclusions from from the td2 overall
where yeah these are also our key
messages and we're very proud that they
the ones in bold is the executive
summary so that we've actually managed
to to get them into a small into a small
slogan we we think and I think yeah from
all looking at all the different cases
and and experiences that we've analyzed
that definitely there is room to
maneuver and that recognizing ecosystem
services by going through the entire
list is an important first step to
create the awareness and then the
conditions to make natural capital work
for local development and human
well-being
we're actually missing the capital in
there no not that I'm aware of but do
they might not have read it the Spanish
translation is not on the web yet
we think it's decisive to adapt
appraisal design to your specific needs
that's what you're supposed to do in
your project so that's very important
work before you get down to the actual
valuation but in order to get useful
results and I think that's that's an
important message to convey to
policymakers they need to understand and
be involved in deciding on what is
actually being measured valued and how
because otherwise these values are just
figures and they might impress them for
a moment but they won't really talk to
them I think that's an important lesson
for example from the Cape Town study but
they are plenty more it's important to
find the right place for your results
and decision making so to quote one of
Poland's favorite sentences if economics
is weaponry then paying attention to
rights and I mean property rights and
the broad things that we've discussed
last time knowledge relating to local
knowledge and and experience like for
example in the Tanzania case and
participation of communities but also of
local administration of you can get line
managers wonderful otherwise opt for the
people who directly work for them and
that will help against backfiring I
think it's decisive to build on the full
range of values there is a huge danger
and that's that's happening in many
places that single services are promoted
are developed at the expense of others
and at the risk of degree degrading the
entire system that doesn't mean you need
to calculate all the values and very
much in favor of prioritizing and
selecting the the ones that are decisive
to your decision problem but I think
it's important to look at all of them
and communicate the importance of all of
them yeah and then
we also strongly believe that it's
better to err on the side of caution
definitely these services and these
values don't tell you something on
system functioning or on thresholds or
potential damage costs so you need
complimentary estimates and expertise to
get a grip on that and if in doubt
better stay on the conservative side the
way forward well we think there is quite
a role of communicating ecosystem
services and their values in whatever
format to make the case to get clarity
on trade-offs in decisions so location
of projects might be decisive specific
design of a conservation measure of of
whatever other measure is can be
decisive and looking into who is
affected by your decision is decisive
there as well you have quite a potential
to increase efficiency of public sector
in in general regarding many areas in in
the Eclair workshop in South Africa we
did an exercise and the we had a
workshop and we asked yeah people from
African municipalities to to rank the
five most important issues in in their
municipality and it I'd say in 80% of
cases they were in one way or other
related to ecosystem services or
ecosystem services improvement could
contribute to resolving them yeah and
then obviously explain explore win-win
options okay with this I'm done with my
lecture and open for any further
questions and discussions
you